let's say that you love frozen yogurt so
every day after school you decide to go
to the frozen yogurt store at exactly
four o'clock
four o'clock p.m
now because you like frozen yogurt so
much you are not a big fan of having to
wait in line when you get there you're
impatient you want your frozen yogurt
immediately
and so you decide to conduct a study you
want to figure out the probability of
there being lines of different sizes
when you go to the frozen yogurt store
after school exactly at four o'clock p.m
so in your study the next 50 times you
observe you go to the frozen yogurt
store at 4 pm you make a series of
observations you observe the size of the
line so let me make two columns here
line
size
is the left column and on the right
column let's say this is the number of
times observed so times
times observed
observed
all right times observed
my handwriting is obs-e
e-r-v-e-d all right times observed
all right so let's first think about
okay so you go and you say hey look i
see no people in line exactly or you see
no people in line exactly 24
times
you see
you see one person in line exactly
18 times
and you see
two people in line exactly eight times
and in your 50 visits you don't see more
than you never see more than two people
in line i guess this is a very efficient
cashier at this at this frozen yogurt
store
so based on this based on what you have
observed what would be the what would be
your estimate of the probabilities of
finding no people in line one people in
line or two people in line on at 4 p.m
on the days after school that you visit
the frozen yogurt store and let's say
you only visit it on weekdays where
there are school days so what's the
probability of there being no line a one
person line or two-person line when you
visit at 4 p.m on a school day
well
all you can do is estimate the true
probability the true theoretical
probability we don't know what that is
but you've done 50 observations here
right this is uh and notice this adds up
to 50 18 plus 8 is 26 26 plus 24 is 50.
so you've done 50 observations here and
so you can figure out well what are the
relative frequencies of having zero
people what is the relative frequency of
one person on the relative frequency of
two people in line and then we can use
that as the estimates for the
probability so let's do that
so probability estimate
i'll do it in the next column
so probability
probability estimate
and once again we can do that by looking
at the relative frequency
the relative frequency of 0 well we
observe that 24 times
out of 50
and so 24 out of 50 is the same thing as
0.48
or you could even say that this is 48
percent
now what's the relative frequency of
seeing one person in line
well you observe that 18 out of the 50
visits
18 out of the 50 visits that would be a
relative frequency 18 divided by 50 0.36
which is 36 percent of your visits and
then finally the relative frequency of
seeing a two-person line that was eight
out of the 50 visits
and so that is zero point
and that is equal to
of the visits and so there's some
interesting things here remember these
are estimates of the probability you're
doing this by essentially sampling what
the line on 50 different days you don't
know it's not going to always be exactly
this but it's it's a good estimate you
did it 50 times
and so based on this you'd say well i'd
estimate the probability of having a
zero person line is 48 percent i'd
estimate that the probability of having
a one person line is 36 percent i'd
a two-person line is 16 or 0.16 and it's
important to realize that these are
legitimate probabilities remember to be
a probability it has to be between 0 and
1.
it has to be zero and one and if you
look at all of the possible events it
should add up to one because at least
based on your observations these are the
possibilities obviously in a real world
there might be some kind of crazy thing
where more people go in line but at
least based on the events that you've
seen these three different events and
these are the only three that you have
observed based on your your observations
it's it these three should act because
these are the only three things you've
observed they should add up to one and
they do add up to one let's see 36 plus
16 is 52 52 plus 48 they add up to one
now if you once you do this you might
do something interesting you might say
okay you know what over over the next
over the next two years you plan on
visiting 500 times
so visit next five visiting
visiting
500 times
so based on your estimates of the
probability of having no line of a
one-person line or a two-person line
how many times in your next 500 visits
would you expect there to be a
two-person line
based on your observation so far
well it's reasonable to say well a a a
good estimate of the number of times
you'll see a two person line when you
visit 500 times well you say well
there's going to be 500 times
and it's a reasonable expectation based
on your estimate of the probability that
0.16 of the time you will you will see
you will see a two-person line or you
could say eight out of every 50 times
and so what is this going to be
let's see 500 divided by 50 is just 10.
so you would expect you would expect
that 80 out of the 500 times you would
see
a
you would see a two-person line now to
be clear i i would be shocked if it's
exactly 80 ends up being the case but
this is actually a very good expectation
based on your observations it is
completely possible first of all that
your observations were were off that you
you know that just this is just the
random chance that you happen to observe
this many or this few times that there
were two people in line so that could be
off but even if
even if these are very good estimates
it's pr it's possible that something
that you maybe you you're you see a two
person line 85 out of the 500 times or
or 65 out of the 500 times all of those
things are possible whenever you think
and it's always very important to keep
in mind you're estimating a two you're
estimating the true probability here
which you it's very hard to know for
sure what the true probability is but
you can make estimates based on sampling
the line on different days by making
these observations by having these
experiments so to speak each of these
observations you could use an experiment
and then you can use those to set an
expectation but none of these things do
know for sure that they're definitely
going to be exactly 80 out of the next
500 times